[Musique]
soir les enfants bon port
nicolas et pimprenelle ont l'air très
sage
j'ai bien l'impression qu'ils sont déjà
couchés nounours méfiez-vous des eaux
dormantes
mon le joueur ne fait pas trop de bruit
pour ne pas les réveiller sommes nous à
grand
popo peu
[Musique]
votre avis mais non ils ne sont pas
couchés peau soir les enfants
approche toi de nous au
soir à dos plein de merveilles vous la
trouvez dans le placard de maman ou leur
creux de mercoeur il est plein de
merveilles
aucun qu'est ce que c'est un tchador
avec jam dessus du
hall à la quelle merveille un coquillage
qu'est ce que tu fais nous j'écoute
j'entends lammer
tient à toi
la mer
et ça encore coquille hommes et encore
un autre
elmer veut il est même note la dame
s'est trop gentil merci le plus qu'ils
ne pourraient coûter la mer ce tournage
et nous on n'écoutera pas mettre les
mâles et vienne et colas alors on lit
[Musique]
on se croirait à la mer quelle merveille
bonne nuit les petits
[Musique]
c'est un lieu
donné
anita prenait fait beau rêve petit frère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit les enfants
mais qu'a fait tu nounours j'écoute le
bruit de labeur repos quel gros
coquillage ce sont mes amis qui m'ont
donné ils sont très gentils auj
on n'y va pas trop à rod nounours ben et
nuit dom
bonsoir bon choix aux
cheveux patron ou là j'oubliais mon le
cheval voilà ça cassait d'être trop
pressés des calmes nounours vous avez
raison du calme nous l'ours ma chère
petite échelle
et
du calme et moux
[Musique]
coucou c'est nous
madame à prônes el
menzah
[Musique]
excellente idée marcheurs mais où est-on
monsieur nicolas
si mes amis
aux routes
[Musique]
sur le pont d'avignon
géré le pont d'avignon ont dit dans ce
monde y dansent sur le pont d'avignon
du dance to seront
[Musique]
le talent qui n'ont ni dans ceux
contenus dans ce bottin inclus dont on
dit dans ce domaine
[Musique]
sur le ton de vie non on est dans ce
taudis danse sur le pont vino conduite
ans tous en rond
[Musique]
à
aaron monsieur nono avant au col pro ben
oui fait chaud avignon et bien belles
dames éprouvé cieux où les allées
[Musique]
oh mais les belles dames ne dorment pas
avec leur collier qui a raison mangoné
nov
non juste un liner
bonne une
bonne nuit n'est celle militaire bonne
nuit et ce talent
[Musique]
connaissez-vous le pont d'avignon patron
non nounours je ne connais pas vous avez
peur c'est un pont formidable et on s'y
amuse vive le pont d'avignon et bien
vive le pont d'avignon bonne nuit les
enfants fait pour eux
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir
alors nounours tu ne veut toujours pas
me dire ce que tu apportes de si
précieux dans son panier mon bon patron
c'est un cadeau de ma soeur humilia elle
me l'a envoyé pour mes deux petits amis
et je descends leur portée à tout à
l'heure on les chope
hop hop hop hop hop
hop
bonsoir les enfants
c'est pas gentil d'être en retard
j'apporte un cadeau pour les enfants qui
ont été sages
c'est pour moi car c'est un jour ça
[Musique]
l'a dit
et puis des cancers
je suis un petit garçon de bella figura
tu veux mieux le pompon et les coûts
futurs
si vous voulez coûteux mais je saurai
bien les mots j'ai la bonne aventure ont
mis la [ __ ] maupu roi
lorsque les petits garçons jeu jacky et
sage on leur donne des pompons de jolies
images
mais quand tu cette fugue route et l'a
fait c'est trop long tenez l'autre
davanture ok la triste aventure
serait sage et bien vous plaire à ma
mère je
serai bien ma leçon
peuplera mon père je veux bien les coups
portés et s'ils levaient les nombreux
c'est la bonne aventure on qu'est la
table avant tout
[Musique]
'nos
s'émerveiller nous aimons tellement les
confitures et cela vous m'en direz des
nouvelles
ma chère soeur emilie a c'est elle qui
les affectent quelques heures dans wii
alors quelques d'or
tu lui diras un grand merci de natra
pain et tu lui feras un gros baiser
au
menu non 110 mm bonne nuit les petits
la chute à la lune
[Musique]
à
connu nicolas fait beau rêve petite
soeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on 120 patron pas avant que tu m'aies
dis ce que tu as apporté à nicolas et
pimprenelle
du conte futur patron mais rassurez vous
j'en ai caché impôts chez nous et nous
allons bien nous régaler
allons en route gros qu aucun boni les
enfants feu de boer
pour ce faire les petits ou soie ou lolo
ce que je suis charger je me demande
nounours ce que tu vas faire avec tout
ce papier vous allez voir patron vous
allez voir
europe
bon le seul propos pom pom pom pom pom
[Musique]
c'est une idée
j'arrive au soir mais au fond
ce que tu cherchais qu'est ce que tu
nous as pas un papier beaucoup de papier
nous allons faire lot d'avions en papier
et nous les enverrons tous sur le nuage
de mon petit pas trop bien début
[Rires]
non
fermez les yeux et compté jusqu'à 3
[Musique]
et voilà
qui
va s'envoler évidemment regardé je
souffle dessus
[Musique]
le haut à vous pas trop
ils veulent bien
lolo
lundi dont trois yachts en avion oh oui
il a changé gratuit voyons voir
pcq on dire
pour l'instant ne soyez pas si précieux
la première les dons reçus à vous deux
ma parole
monsieur
[Musique]
les enfants rois
quelle drôle de lettres ignorera de crue
mais
voilà des pick up des sapins ça veut
dire que quand il joue est à la montagne
des chefs d'état d'un les dab dab à eau
il se plie et se déplie
là qui les accompagnent elle n'est pas
pas de commission tous les soirs je de
la culture vous rendormir son petit
garçon
allons au lit comme votre petite amie
corps du show la commission
salue on va décrire tu sais bonne nuit
les petits
là j'étais là leur
dos au mur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci nounours il est très beau en avion
je les ai reçus sur le nez oui aux
patrons je voulais vous en expédier
encore beaucoup d'autres mais nous avons
reçu de lettre de cornichons j'ai oublié
dans me and north allant en route bonne
nuit des enfants faute de boer heures
par les enfants bon soit
aulas vieux patron je me sens en pleine
forme
también north moi aussi ma petite
échelle les robes hop hop hop hop hop
hop au robot
alors il n'y a personne
ces prix sont les pharmacies
[Musique]
mon dieu ce n'est pas mon petit nicolau
j'ai alors je vais te tue 3 7 passes des
tisanes mais attention c'est très chaud
moi je prends des médicaments
petit nico ou le bon ce fonds
mechaal et repos
voilà que médicament de menu comment je
ne sais moi j'en veux plus eu de la
bonne dizaine mon petit nico lors à
l'afp disent ah et des baumes et people
mexicana tu as tort nicolas c'est
délicieux les médicaments j'aime
beaucoup les médicaments et je vais en
prendre pour ne pas attraper la grippe
nous
laponie tisane
sais pas si on est où là
[Musique]
le merveilleux siro capecchi pee wee de
pilules c'est ce qu'il ya de meilleur tu
parles tu fais peut-être une petite
friction pas une petite mais une grande
assiette mais tu vois nicollin eh bien
elle n'est pas vouloir que c'est pas de
chance ben ça oui alors tu ne regrette
rien
vraiment faire dodo la friction
patronale
[Musique]
[Rires]
pas si fort ou le banc quelle force
ou le nom au rouge très bonne
nomination
oui et non
cette annonce
crim ce que j'ai chaud je transpire
merci pas pr neil je me sens bien au sco
jeune franc bien nicolas prend des
médicaments demain si tu veux être guéri
d'accord nano cela
j'éteins la lumière
ce que je me sens bien
[Musique]
ah voici notre nounou oui
je me sens tout drôle patron tu après
trop de médicaments on ne prend pas de
médicaments quand on n'est pas malade je
me sens tout visant allons en route gros
nigo ocz bonne nuit les enfants photo
bourg
par les enfants bon ce
patron mes deux petits amis ont l'air
bien calme ce soir j'espère que nicolas
a bien pris ses médicaments ajouté sans
voix mon cher petit dico lent je lui
apportais d'un flore n'oublie pas que tu
n'es pas malade toi nounours et que tu
ne dois pas prendre de médicaments je
préfère me soigner avec du miel patron
ma chère petite échelle
l'europe
[Musique]
fait au cola montpetit flemme faite aux
doutes aux radios loup fait dodo colle à
mon petit frère cet autoradio loup maman
étant qui fait des gâteaux papa est en
bas qui fait du chocolat fait tout au
col à mon petit frère c'est au doctorat
du lot cet autocollant petit frère c'est
tout doute aura du loup si tu es mignon
tu as raté mon bon si tu ne dors pas tu
n'auras pas fait de joe cole à mon petit
frère fait au doctorat du lot fait doux
doux comme un petit frère fait doux
d'août aura du lourd
bonsoir les enfants
ne fait pas trop de bruit nos noces
nicolas s'est endormi comment vas-tu
pour coup mais il s'est bien laisser
soigner demain il sera trop tard ribéry
et il pourra se lève et je lui ai
apporté quelques flore merci gilles vous
donnerai pas matin et trois membres au
neubourg ce conte par têtu trois glands
mur tu veux pas quelques médicaments
tu n'as pas très bonne mine tu sais tu
trouves ou quelques petites piles ou
quel serait le plus grand bien non au
public tu préfères peut-être un petit
air charisme ou une bonne petite
friction meinau nul autre merci tu n'es
dope à dallas non je suis bien portants
non tu fais pas de sirop nous
gamin
c'était un délice sociaux on y est
[Musique]
je crois que tout pas preuve
d'un gros phares chers amis ne nous aime
bonne nuit la jette à la lumière
[Musique]
alors nounours
et tue tous oui je tousse
j'ai dû prendre froid patron rentrant
vite
je vais me soigner avec du miel oui mon
bon nounours banni les enfants ou
fêtes de bourg
pour le cheval a tout de suite patron ne
soit pas si pressés nous nous les amis
m'attendent ce qu'ils vont être contents
boom pow pow pow pow pow pow bonsoir les
enfants vous aussi vous allez être très
content car nounours vous a réservé une
belle surprise
bonsoir le petit
[Musique]
oui une nouvelle histoire très jolie
inistre
l'histoire d'une petite fille allons je
veux pause
[Musique]
il y avait une fois il n'ya pas très
longtemps une petite fille ronde et
coquine que son papa et sa maman appelez
philippines qui nous disait
[Musique]
un jour alors que sa maman tricotait
assises dans leur jardin et que
philippines était en train de manger le
grosse tartine de confiture deux frères
elle vit passer un lapin blanc à tous
lapin ado lapin cria philippines mais le
lapin blanc parti en courant et
philippine se mit à le pourchasser en
criant
et la maman de philippine qui avait fini
son tricot se mit à la recherche de sa
petite fille ronde et coquine et ne la
trouvons pas rentrer a dans sa maison
très inquiète
le papa de philippines 13 en colère dj
mais où est elle mathilde
lorsqu'on frappe à la porte c'était un
agent de police qui ramenait la petite
fille qui
parce qu'elle n'est pas no elle pleurait
parce que la vraie fin ce garnement de
lapin blanc avait mangé toute la tartine
de confiture de frein ça vient faire non
et après nous philippines fit un bon
repas que lui avait préparé sa maman
pour la consoler et elle se couchant et
en s'endormant elle murmure un auto
lapin à temps et le lendemain matin
le long de momentum
qui s'est passé je ne me rappelle plus
j'ai oublié d'apporter la suite
je vous la porterez une prochaine fois
je vous laisse le livre vous êtes
content elle est très jolie
pas d'apporter ce produit allons les
enfants ou les
eaux ne nuit les petits
là j'ai
fait deux tours
[Musique]
patron si vous aviez vu leur joie le
cher petit elle était très jolie ton
histoire oui oh je l'aurais fait cadeau
du livre au mou s'en va en route bonne
nuit tous nos amis fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ont droit
boussois aux patrons le vieux bob très
belle north ma petite fiole
[Musique]
prolongé
à l'honneur
[Musique]
du colloque paroles
incriminées
bonsoir cas prouvé
que je pense t-il ou le l'on
savait
pas où ce cours va voir ce qui ce passe
ma petite pas preneur je crois qu'on
tient plus du courage et
[Musique]
à l'eau a
beaucoup bougé pop ou
[Musique]
sylvie lacome admiratrices voilà au but
à vue est un peu aux bonnes
et wittes il souffle en eau
alema les âges pas où vous ou coup au
secours
[Musique]
kourosh bourse votre poule
voilà j veu
[Musique]
où les boeufs voilà
où ça les
petits comme relevé dans votre villa que
je vois le bout de votre nez
prenez un peu ici
le petit cowboy
laisse les petits comme aux grands
qu'ils ne se boucher
le nez north
optique autant tu as voulu me faire paul
tu vas voir tu vas voir la prochaine
fois c'est moi qui te ferait blog
[Rires]
ne pourrait pas fâché alors bonne nuit
petit drôle
[Musique]
alors courage nounours on s'est bien
amusés patron ce que jury
tu n'as pas eu peur moi bord
allons en route ayrault bonne nuit les
enfants allez vite vous coucher on
brassait d'haufor oparo les feux de boue
re
[Musique]
bonsoir
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui nicolas et
pimprenelle sont sages n'en doute pas
patron je vais faire l'école ce soir et
vous savez bien que tous les enfants
aiment beaucoup les camps très bien
monsieur l'instituteur appelez moi
plutôt professeur patron je suis le
professeur nounours bon l'épaule
bon courage professeur nounours pop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
on demande encore un jouet soir à
l'adapter aux non pas la poupée
non alors nicolas tu n'as pas l'air de
bonne humeur mon bonhomme ennuis on sait
pas quand va jouer ce soir on ne joue
pas au travail
et nous on travaille bien tu sais maman
appelez moi dont professeur nounours car
vous êtes mes élèves
protestaient rnic allons mes élèves
prenez du papier de crayon
[Musique]
ne pas besoin d'être grand juste quatre
ou cinq ans il suffit tout simplement de
se conduire châtiment lamballe l'îcone
on s'assied sur mende en est tout seul
elle le prend et pimentent pts mais sans
que tout le monde est content on venait
quand kelly quand on veut s'amuser la
jolie les connes à la grande maison où
l'on à des trayons où l'on fait que
bompas temps où l'on chante des chansons
à la gentille et qu'avec deux filles et
deux garçons on y apprend qu'ils le sont
on joue avec un ballon ovale et les
créations au jeu fut signalé je veux ta
campagne et parce que c'est à l'école
con comme des amis les grands et petits
et qui prouve que ça aussi on l'aimera
tout ça vous vieux qui veulent l'école
nous aime aussi aller pour les calculs
et on rirait pour dessiner comme
aimeraient pour gagner
[Musique]
[Rires]
et oui n'est pas si notre professeur
nous nous
salah et le portier ya là on a dû faire
trop de bruit pendant leurs grâces ion
ce pays
d'accord patron nous allons unis ne met
pas en colère tu vois on y va
bonne nuit qui marchande samm bien on
fera mieux de votre part et dîner quand
sera très sage la prochaine fois
bonne nuit petit frère fait pour eve
grande soeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous n'avez pas l'air content professeur
nounours oh alors aux eaux ils sont
heureux pour ce soir
mais ce n'était pas une vraie école
nounours c'était une école pour rire et
pour s'amuser paul furlan un patron le
professeur nounours est bien déçu ne
soyez pas tristes professeur vos petits
élèves m'ont promis d'être très sage la
prochaine fois j'espère bien bonne nuit
les petits faute d'eau pour
[Musique]
le plot
l'euro notre nounours et bien joyeux ce
soir à tron nous allons nous amuser je
connais des devinettes très difficile
que nicolas et pimprenelle ne
connaissent pas et qu'ils ne trouveront
jamais
il me tarde de voir ça c'est moi qui
vais être le plus fort ce soir europe on
échelle hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
bombes au
phosphore ni colle en bronze pas preneur
écoutez moi bien le premier on lit à
granules
je lui pose une de zinal
et tous les deux en même temps la vigne
et bien je vous poserai peu devinettes
et vous jouerez tous les deux
voyons au louvre pour entrer on la ferme
quand on sort
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
elle a aussi une clu
mais oui moi je les aime pas la dînette
de porte à une autre elle est très
difficile celle là
elle mange beaucoup d'herbe et elle fait
[Musique]
bravo nicolas
allons y l'état
voyons né à bell le fabrique et les
enfants le monde
qu'est-ce que seul
[Musique]
oui
il aime beaucoup
une dernière on se couche pas dans es on
se cache dessous qu'est ce que c'est
allons ce facile
mais c'est le lit
de talent vous y un ours et vous dormez
la jette à la lui bien
bonne nuit
en une annonce l'année
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants le bourreau
arval elles nourrissent patron j'étais
le plus fort ce soir ils n'ont pas
trouvé mais deux finales vraiment
nounours enfin bras tout le rôle alors
la route mon nounours bah nu les enfants
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette
bien vous laver les dents robra sur vos
parents est fait pour eux
[Musique]
e